thinking deeply about a simple thing
right once you arrive at the quadratic
formula you kind of feel like ah I got
to like this result and it is
fantastically powerful but you should
just stop there and say well great now I
can use it you should think about well
what else does this review okay so let's
just yeah so what can we get out of this
first let me remind you of something
which I dealt with very very briefly and
I said I'm gonna do this a bit more in
the future a bit more probably now I'm
doing it we have noticed that underneath
the square root
there's something very very important
something decisive in fact right it's so
important it gets its own name and I
told it to force out to the date the
discriminant very good so we say we
replaced that with with the Greek Delta
for D right so we could say it is where
we define the discriminant as this turn
you remember from completing the square
where it came from but that's what it is
okay now if you recall where we're doing
graphing right I said we determine that
when you have certain kinds of graphs
like say it is or this particular kinds
of things give you restrictions right so
whatever X you've got a restriction on
the x2 can't be equal to zero
right so that gives you a domain y
equals log base 2 of X there's another
restriction on the X namely that X has
to be positive right because 2 raised to
any power no matter what how you raise
it to won't give you a negative note bus
so therefore X must be positive now it
also is the other important category of
functions which gave you restrictions
what is these guys right in this case
it's just slightly different from these
right X can't equal 0 X also can equal 0
X can't equal to 0 for this you can't
take the square root of 0 it's fine but
then off that you've got to get positive
right so being that we have square roots
and other kinds of functions
yes restrictions that's what you notice
here since the discriminant is
underneath the square root it tells us
something point of things okay so let's
try and get this down for me number one
so this is the discriminant depending on
what you know about the discriminant
that will tell you very many useful
properties of the quadratic you're
looking at right now this should ring
some bells but I'm going to go through
this in more detail we went before okay
so firstly if the discriminant are
positive number I do mean strictly
positive so that's more including zero
right what that means is you remember -
be on to a in the quadratic formula
there's your axis of symmetry right and
then plus or minus B in scope plus a
little bit - a little bit to go to get
your two roots okay so if you've got a
positive discrimination distance and the
bigger the discriminant is then further
away you're getting does that make sense
so exclusio means two distinct meeting
not at the same spot right not at the
same value two distinct real roots and
we'll come back to this meeting of real
in a second okay two distinct real roots
they're not at the same spot
alternatively if the discriminant is
exactly equal to zero right you're going
from this axis of symmetry right - Bo to
a but then when you go plus or minus you
you don't go anywhere because the
discriminant is zero right so instead of
getting two distinct roots you can say
this in one of two ways you could say
either you get one what we call a double
root okay the double grip because when
you think about this these roots here
are different in nature to this root
right they are actually doing different
things right it's not just that I've got
two of them in the same spot so we call
it double root alternatively you might
see it written as two equal roots right
is route and then there's another one on
exactly the same spot okay and all all
as the as the couple weeks unfolded even
in turn four when we look at a new topic
in extension 2 you get to see some of
the reason why some managers like to say
to equal roots even though quite
obviously it only intersects once it's a
bit of a funny way to say well there
will be a really important reason why
okay now and the suitors positive to
sweet is equal to zero there's another
important thing which is that for either
of these if the discriminant is exactly
equal to a square number if I have
something under here right that ends up
being a square root sorry a square
number when you take the square root you
won't have a Suren ymore right cuz for
example if I have the square root of 25
okay the square root 25 is 5 so I have
all rational numbers up here now I still
might not have a whole number because
depending on what 2a is I still might
have some kind of fraction in there ok
but I'm not gonna have said any more
right so in other words I have rational
roots the certs go away just quickly
going back to x squared plus 5x plus 6
you get so much mileage out of a single
quadratic right let's my god the
discriminative 4x squared plus 5x plus 6
because you already know what the result
is right for that the distribute is
going to be XK plus 5 s plus 6 what's B
squared 25 riken's 5 squared minus 4a
see see it by the way just as a matter
of my own personal convention I ride my
4ac like this that's just to help me
remember there's a 4 and then there's
another thing and then there's another
thing because sometimes you know it's
sort of demonic that you forget to
multiply by a so I do this just to help
me remember there's three things in
there so of course that 25 minus 24
which is a square number right
so there's your two roots which you
already knew so that's all fine okay
one more category positive zero
okay sir again just like with the case
they're just gonna be Sigma's right
there are two ways to say this first I
could say um no real Ritz okay
don't exist right so a classic example
is the one I gave you just now y equals
x squared plus 1 now despite the fact
that there's no B in there
BX it's still in general form right and
is equal to 1 B is equal to 0 C is equal
to 1 so in this case what's the
discriminant 0 that's B squared minus 4
a c right sir negative 4 now what does
this mean it tells you what you already
knew namely that this thing never
collides with the x-axis because if it
did you'd have some values going on in
here but right now you have something
the drakes described so I say no real
roots but another way to say this is
what I have is 2 well if roots aren't
real you'd call them unreal now by the
way just as a little side note and I'm
not going to do with it now because we
will deal with it in turn four okay it
says something about the history of
mathematics and how it's developed that
there are two categories of numbers that
both literally seem to be making fun of
those categories of numbers right
that's not accidental I don't it's a
good thing but there's a real historical
reason why they have those names and to
say something irrational means it
doesn't make sense right well that's
what the great